thank you for the um unnecessarily
wonderful introduction I really
appreciate the chance to come here and
um and and meet everyone and U and visit
Montreal it's been really nice the um
this talk is a kind of a summary talk of
uh physical modeling um you know as as
Gary mentioned I've been involved in
this area uh since the 80s it's a really
uh Rich area there there are a lot of
directions you can go in and it's very
easy to go down a direction and and and
and become specialized it's it's so big
that really it's almost imposs to do all
of it so for example if you're a string
person uh I would say I'm primarily a
string person um having come up in that
tradition it's very difficult to do
Woodwinds for example you know they're
really very different uh rich areas and
so this this talk is is going to be my
summary of uh uh based on uh you know
the work that I've had some involvement
in over the years and uh and it's it's
going to summarize really about three
decades and also I we extended it a
little earlier you'll
see so so I'll start with some of the
early ideas kind of organize things in a
historical order uh just so you can sort
of see the way things evolved through
time and um and then land and then work
working through those various examples
and then and then sort of uh as a
postlude talk about some of the more
recent work works that that's ongoing
right now at Karma and let me know if
I'm uh if I'm making it impossible to
read something so early ideas uh
physical modeling uh synthesis and
effects you know sort of an overview
and well okay but I need my walking
exercise so
back so um yeah that that's an idea so
um I I'll try to emphasize you know just
kind of a high level review uh sound
examples block diagrams and and the
historical
ordering next slide
please so
[Laughter]
so uh so this is the uh building at Cara
this is the null on Stanford campus and
and so what I'm talking about will be
from that perspective because it was
here where um I've been doing my work I
actually showed up there in 77 as a uh
as a student actually as an engineer
just a volunteer engineer from Silicon
Valley and then got into the program and
and U did my graduate student years
there and I've gone away for short
periods and come back but that that's
that's the uh the bias you know okay but
to go back to the beginning or let's say
the mathematical beginning in physical
Insight
beginning uh you can go all the way back
to Daniel
beri and dalan
bear and what's interesting is that
within 11 years of each other they sort
of launched two major branches of audio
synthesis uh what we uh often call
Spectral modeling and physical modeling
so I'm going to concentrate on phys
physical modeling today which is is
which is this one it was launched by D
Bear's paper on the first wave equation
for the ideal vibrating string and its
solution in the form of traveling waves
and so that um and that's not the U only
way to do physical modeling but it's a
very efficient way and that's that's the
area that I've been uh concentrating
very efficient realtime models because
ultimately we want to use these things
as musical instruments in real time and
and the nice thing about basing them on
on physical models is that all
performance information can make it into
the sound so you don't sacrifice
performability now spectral modeling is
you can think of as based on forier
theorem and it goes back before forier
you know forier was in the 1800s and and
you could say that forer's theorem was
getting started really with d with uh
bruli and uh Oiler and then later lrange
and and then finally uh uh you know
forier proved forier theorem but but
they were trying to approximate General
functions with sums of sin waves sine
waves um much earlier and and you could
say it started with bruli who who
described physical vibration as a
superposition of simple harmonic
vibration which was a pure sinusoidal
vibration and this expression of it um
is by Oiler somewhat afterwards so Oiler
did a lot of the heavy lifting on the
mathematical
formulations but beri had the original
physical insight and and that's what
launched the superposition of of
harmonic vibration you could say modal
synthesis came out of that and and then
in contrast we have D Bear's
formulation uh leading to traveling
waves and they look pretty different but
but yet these both describe a vibrating
string so how can these be reconciled
and a lot of effort went into
reconciling these very different
mathematical formulations of vibrating
string motion in fact it went on for
decades and and lrange at one point said
that the vibrating string problem made
him sick he actually got really tired of
it because it just drove a lot of deep
mathematical U
investigation so now the way dalan bear
came up with his formulation was to take
uh Brook Taylor's restoring Force so
Taylor of Taylor series Fame came up
with this uh restoring Force as the
string tension times the second
derivative or the curvature so that was
the restoring force on the vibrating
string and then Dal bear plugged that
into Newton's second law of motion f
equals Ma so this is your F and then ma
is just the string
density uh mass is the string density
times length and then acceleration is
the second derivative with respected
time and so there you have the wave
equation for the ideal vibrating string
and it's just you know FAL ma a and so
then he went on so that was then
published he published it in a kind of a
differential form so if you cross
multiply by the uh you know the Delta X
and delta T you get the sort of
differential calculus form that he
published but you know you divide
through and you get the modern wave
equation and so that that was when it
began but then he also solved it he he
solved it and and found that
any any traveling wave shape to the left
and right would solve this uh wave
function this this this wave equation so
the the the the string displacement at
time T in position X is given by a right
goinging wave y+ and and so any function
of the form T minus X over C is some
shape moving to the right at speed C
that's just a mathematical identity and
then y minus any function of t plus X
see is is a shape moving to the left at
speed
C okay and then um relating it back to
the wave equation we have to have C
equals uh tension over density so this
is this is a you know first deep theory
of strings that that tells you that the
wave propagation speed is proportional
to the square root of the tension and
inversely proportional to the square
root of the density and and that's the
beginning of U I would say a physical
theory of vibrating
strings and
so um that led to some interesting
paradoxes the ones that made lrange ill
at some point the uh the basic problem
is how can you equate this traveling
wave formulation
to uh sum of simple harmonic vibrations
you know so the this um harmonic
vibration view so here we have the time
variation so it's just a sinusoid at
frequency new and then there's the
spatial variation which is sinusoidal
and then you have some arbitrary
amplitude so it's like a sum of tuning
Forks so so this mathematics says you
can pluck a string and send waves going
back and forth or you can take as many
tuning Forks as you have overtones and
hit them all at the right time and
you'll get a pluck string sound so that
that was the U Paradox you know how
could that be because um you know in
modern terms you'd say that these are
standing waves they're they're just VI
vibrations in place and these are
so-called Progressive waves how can you
make how can a progressive wave be made
out of standing waves for example when
you first pluck the string let's say you
pluck it at one end and you send a
disturbance propagating at speed C how
do you represent that as a sum of sign
waves that are all over the string I
mean the whole string uh is is uh made
up of sin each of these sine waves goes
the full length of the string so it
looks impossible to even set up the
initial pluck that situation and and and
and what they were wrestling with was 4A
Theory and and we know now that it's not
a problem you just take the 48 transform
of that initial shape and that gives you
the U harmonic overtone weights and it
just happens to be an infinite Series so
what really tripped people up is that it
was an infinite sum and with an infinite
sum you can do almost anything and uh it
took them a long time to come to grips
with
that now it was interesting also to look
at what sound was in this this day sound
was not a superposition of simple tones
it was a simple it was a superposition
of pulse it was a pulse train and and
these are Big heavyweight names uh of
the day Oiler Delan bear and L gr they
all agreeed that tonal sound was a
periodic pulse train and the pulse shape
was not critical it didn't really matter
what the details of the shape were now
we know now that the 48 Transformer of
that pulse shape is the envelope of the
spectrum and it matters a lot but you
know in those days they didn't have
Spectrum analyzers and and uh they
didn't have computers so they were
unable to really see the importance of
the pul
shape now of course
beri uh said well uh there's something
more fundamental here all right and you
could say that pipe organs of the day
did a kind of additive synthesis but it
was not mixing sinusoids it was mixing
Elementary sounds like readed sounds and
and uh flu sounds like flute flute
sounding uh voices and you have you know
different octaves and registers so
you're doing an additive synthesis in
terms of natural waveforms and you get a
kind of added synthesis like we have
today but it's just not boiled down to
sums of sinusoids as we often do now and
and this idea of of approximating
physical shapes with sinusoids they
thought it was just a mathematical
artifice uh it didn't have physical
meaning it was just a mathematical uh
expansion you could do they they did
have tailor series and so you could do
trigonometric series expansion of
functions and that was interesting
mathematically but it was not physics
but beri thought it was physics and he
had the original so what he had was the
Insight of superposition the idea that
uh linear system well in modern terms
linear systems have sinusoids as igen
functions and igen functions um go in
and come out looking the same so if you
put a sinusoid into an a linear system
it comes out a sinusoid and it's the
same frequency if it's a linear time
invariance
system so beri had this original insight
into
superposition so he thought they had
separate physical existence in other
words he saw separate physical uh
component vibrations and d and Barett
you know they wrote back and forth to
each other um in in the literature and D
bear said that can't be possibly right
because of V modulation and and this is
actually still a valid criticism for a
speaker because imagine a low frequency
in a speaker and now you add a high
frequency so now it's going to wiggle
fast as it goes slowly well you're going
to get a a variable Doppler shift on
that high frequency that that low
frequency is going to be moving the high
frequency uh and so it's going to go up
as the low frequency diaphragm comes
toward you and then as it reaches its
Excursion limit and and starts to turn
around and go backward then you're going
to get a negative dopper shift so you're
going to get this modulation and you do
so you know the um the the takeaway is
that you should only allow one sinusoid
per loudspeaker so when you when you
have the question how many loudspeakers
do I need that's that's the limit and D
bear foresaw this problem but of course
you know you can neglect it to a good
degree of approximation the inter
modulation is fairly low and the ear
listens to the upper Spectrum in a very
strong way so so a lot of low-l stuff
just doesn't get heard due to auditory
masking and in fact the ear is built
around that idea that that you want to
take sound and break it down into its
frequency components that's the basic
mechanics of hearing and him Holtz uh
was the first to show this that the ear
is a kind of forier analyzer and so the
ear does a kind of fora transform it it
basically takes a frequency and Maps it
to a particular place place along the
Bas of our membrane so that it has its
own little bundle of hair cells going
into the auditory nerve so so the brain
wants a spectrum through time and and so
uh so br's Insight was uh was was
followed by
Evolution and here's a paper that I this
is the best single paper that I found
for this early historical information
it's a fairly recent paper as such
things go so deral the acoustic Origins
of harmonic
analysis in the archive for history of
the exact Sciences so I I recommend that
if you like this interesting uh early um
ideas development then I really
recommend that paper strongly so to
summarize the early U points of view uh
beri saw the superposition of harmonic
vibrations dalen bear saw the uh
formulated the traveling wave
solution and now we know that they're
interchangeable and it's through 48
theory that that it's interchangeable so
for example if you want to do a standing
wave point of view or what we would call
a spectral modeling point of view then
your your basis functions are sinusoids
and for a vibrating string it's the
sinusoids that fit a whole number of
periods in in the string length and you
can take any arbitary string shape and
project it onto those uh sinusoids and
that's just a an inner product uh or a
fora integral so you just multiply that
shape Whatever It Is by a sinusoid
integrate and boom you've got the
coefficient for that component and
that's we think of that as geometric
projection you're finding the shadow of
the original shape onto that particular
direction in space where uh the
frequency determines the direction so
now you can also uh of course do that
for um um the progressive wave model
because a standing wave is a
superposition of uh traveling waves and
so I have a a video for
that this is uh whoops thought I clicked
on
that am I in the did I not I must have
missed
it
okay it was
available let's
see let's see I might have it cached
actually thank you memory um let me find
a good
one yeah that's that that's a good one
so um this shows so down here in blue we
have the standing wave and so it's not
going anywhere it's just sitting there
standing waves have fixed nodes and and
usually they'll have an antinode at the
walls for acoustic pressure standing
wave and you can see that uh such a wave
can be uh just given by a simple
superposition of two traveling waves in
the the opposite direction so the net
motion is nowhere but it's made of two
moving Progressive waves so this was uh
the solution to the Paradox how you can
create um uh standing waves out of PR uh
Progressive waves so there's really no
problem but getting to this from
effectively 48 Theory to took quite a
while to work
out and then the only other demo is this
one this is showing how a pluck
string which you know is initially this
uh shape here you can expand that into a
for expansion and these are the uh
components so this shows you the initial
string shape given by a
sinusoidal uh fundamental of this shape
and then the second harmonic third
harmonic fourth harmonic and so when you
add those sinusoids up you get an
approximation sort of a
filtered approximation and if you just
keep going up in frequency in the limit
as you go to an infinite frequency uh
for the overtones you will get exactly
the U sharp uh leaning triangle initial
shape with its corner so you will you
know reach that corner in the limit even
though it would think you would think
that signing waves can't do that and so
that was U that was a difficult
mathematical
stage
okay so now that's the um early ideas
section the historical um leading up to
the modern day um and so now I want to
fast forward to the
1950s uh first published in early 60s
and you could say it's the first digital
implementation of the progressive wave
model of D bear so we'll call it digital
dalon bear
synthesis and so the the
U the model here is called the uh Kelly
lock bomb model because John Kelly and
Carol lock bomb published in ' 62 this
model of uh an acoustic vocal tract
model and so it's an exact model of this
idealized piecewise cylindrical model so
the the vocal folds are here and you
emit glottal pulses at the base of the
vocal tract and then it's assumed that
plane waves will travel down uh the axis
of the tube and when and and then the
tube geometry changes discontin ously
for the next cylindrical segment and
each cylindrical segment is the same
height and what happens there is that a
plane wave will partially reflect and
transmit and that's called
scattering and so you have some
reflection coefficient and some
transmission coefficient and that's what
you see here um well this actually
should have a delay there should be uh a
delay here equal to this propagation
delay or I could say there's a
reflection right at the entrance and
then there's the first reflection
coefficient and the first transmission
coefficient and then from the other
direction you have the same thing going
on so if a plane wave comes in from this
way it reflects with opposite reflection
coefficient and that's just because the
tube uh is getting uh narrower instead
of larger so that that changes the sign
of the reflection coefficient and so
that's why um oh and I have to introduce
a notational
convention uh box equals
minus yeah that I just discovered that
there's some font problem for certain
figures and uh and and so we'll just
make that notational adjustment uh so so
this is minus K1 because it's stepping
uh in the opposite direction and then
the uh backward reflection uh
transmission coefficient is also one
minus
K1 denoted by the Box
operator um so okay so that that's the
model and and it Mak amazingly good
voice I mean it's it looks like a pretty
crude approximation because you know our
vocal tracks are not piecewise
cylindrical but if you have a lot of uh
cylinders you can you can follow a shape
pretty well and it turns out that what
we need out of this are the first three
resonances to be about right you know
that that turns out to be all you really
need for a good vowel
sound so uh let's hear how it sounds
they Kelly and lock bomb collaborated
with Max
Matthews uh Max Matthews the father
computer music who uh Ed Bell Labs uh
did you know the music 5 acoustic
compiler and um you pioneered computer
music as we know it and he collaborated
with uh Kelly and lock bomb at Bell labs
and and did this example Max did the
musical accompaniment and U uh Kelly and
lock bomb did the uh the singing
[Music]
voice
you
so that that's pretty for listening
that's the same model that's the same
model so um way back in the early 1960s
that could have been worked on in the
late 50s um that that that is a a pretty
good uh voice synthesis even by today's
standards just I would say largely
because most voice synthesis is is all
about intelligibility and and so there
hasn't been a lot of work I mean we we
know some people who've worked on it but
but there has not been relatively nearly
as much work on making the quality of of
uh synthesized voice uh very very
good okay so now fast forward again so
here we are in the early 60s now we're
fast forwarding to uh uh what I was
involved with at Karma and that is
digital waveguide models um starting
around 1985 and so what is a digital
wave guide that it's another dalon bear
building block you have a pair of delay
lines to simulate these Progressive
waves and the reason for that is these
are really cheap a delay line is
implemented using a circular buffer in
memory so it's an order one computation
if you know you know computational
complexity notation meaning that every
sample of sound all you do is you know
um read memory write memory and Advance
a pointer so uh that that's a very very
low complexity for implementing
effectively an entire string okay so
it's make taking advantage of the
traveling wave components as fixed
shapes in the idea deal strength now you
know we in practice we have to uh
introduce losses and dispersion and
nonlinear there all these things we have
to add on but the basic starting point
is extremely efficient and that's
extremely important for realtime
computational models for something that
you can play as a performer and and uh
that that's always a requirement in in
this domain I mean we may do things
offline at first but ultimately it needs
a boil down to something that runs in
real time and that is fully expressive
that that renders all Nuance of
performance so this not only does
strings but it'll do BS uh it can do any
plane wave um it's a plain wave
simulator you can also simulate conical
waves in which case you have samples of
a of an expanding spherical wave or or
Contracting spheric spherical wave and
one other thing you need is the wave
impedance so R denotes the wave
impedance um I mentioned the speed of
sound is the U square root of uh tension
over density well the wave impedance is
the square root of tension times density
and uh it's a very valuable number
because you can take the uh the
traveling in in acoustical uh waves you
can take the traveling
pressure and divide it by the waving pen
to get the traveling velocity and uh
this is something that uh Lord rley
seems to be the first to have published
that that uh that way that acoustical
pressure and velocity are directly
proportional in a traveling wave and
that real positive proportionality
coefficient is the wave impedance and in
the string it's the square root of
tension time density in air it's uh it's
you know gamma times the it is
effectively the volume springiness times
the density of
air okay so what happens when you hook
two of these together so if you hook up
two digital wave guides you get
scattering just like in the Kelly lock
bomb uh context the impedance is
changing from R1 to R2 so you get a a
reflection coefficient K1 given by that
expression again boxing know it's minus
and then uh the transmission
coefficients as before uh so this is
what you would do for example if you
want to have a vibrating string uh
suddenly change its density or or you
have a way of maybe changing its uh
tension uh and and and it's more
important in the acoustic bore context
where you know you have cylindrical
segments changing all right so back to
Strings you can say that um this delay
line models the string and what we're
really explicitly simulating are the
progressive wave components and so for a
pluck string you put in the uh you put
in half of the initial pluck and then
half of the initial pluck is going in
the other direction and by symmetry uh
they need to be equal because you know
they add together to give you the
initial uh string shape and then as time
starts to go they they go in opposite
directions and the equality of them uh
pertains to the fact that there's no
lateral Motion in the pluck um another
way of saying it is that there's initial
velocity of zero so it's an initial
position with a zero initial velocity if
you introduce nonzero initial velocity
then you'll introduce an asymmetry in
those traveling wave components and then
these minus one Reflections at the end
uh correspond to an infinite Impe
impedance so the bridge impedance is
modeled as Infinity the nut impedance is
modeled as infinity and that'll give you
just a simple minus one and and one
another thing we do a lot is commute the
diagram so so this minus one can be
commuted with this delay line and
combined with that one to make it go
away and you can Comm uh you can add
these delay lines together and just get
one delay line with a feedback loop
around it and and yet you can see that
as a physical model of a
string and and so now here's an ideal
initial stru string in this case we
choose velocity waves for the wave
variable and uh if the hammer strikes
the string on a piano uh in this
idealized world then there's a momentum
transfer and so the the width of the
hammer is the width of this rectangle
and so after the strike there's some
velocity here that that that con that
conserves momentum so you take the mass
of the hammer times its striking
velocity that's the momentum that has to
exist in the string uh when you're done
and so that equation is expressing
that so we can do ideal pluck strings
and ideal uh struck strings without
spinning much computation these are
really Dirt Cheap this is still an order
one computation so we can get a lot of
these strings in real time we can pluck
them we can uh we can strike them now
completely independently of that story
uh a Compu two computer science students
Kevin carplus and Alex
strong discovered an interesting
algorithm that uh they called it the
digitar algorithm because it obviously
sounded like a guitar and so here is the
block diagram this is kind of a signal
processing rendering uh I mean they
would not draw a diagram like that
because you know they were computer s
guys they were working on a on a uh an
8bit
microprocessor and they were doing wave
table synthesis and they found that you
know that was kind of boring and and we
all you know anyone who's worked with
Luke waveforms knows that they're pretty
boring they almost sound like some kind
of
orgon but so you have to do something
with them and of course we do envelopes
we do frequency modulation we do lots
and lots of them detuned there are all
these tricks we have for making them not
sound so boring well Alex strong had the
interesting idea why don't we modify the
table as we go through and and what he
could afford to do in his 8bit
microcomputer is um add the current
sample to the previous sample and then
WR shift one bit you know of course he's
in fix point in eight bits and then
write that into the table so overwrite
the table with the twoo average of the
last Red sample and the previously last
red sample and so that's basically a
twoo average smoothing and so you're low
pass filtering the the the table every
time you go through it and this is the
uh low pass filter so we would say this
is a one zero um f low pass filter and
and so this was how it would look if you
diagrammed it up and they discovered it
back in
1978 and they tried a lot of different
uh excitations and and settled on random
numbers as their favorite okay and
that's really interesting to me because
it random numbers are are are really
different from an initial leaning
triangle um if you if you now take the
physical interpretation of that diagram
and back everything out random numbers
correspond to a random pluck position
and a random initial velocity at every
sample along the string so you're you're
simultaneously plucking and striking the
string everywhere along its length so
this is an example of something that you
can do very easily in the virtual world
that that uh that piano makers clavier
makers and guitar makers would have a
very hard time doing and and I can also
say that just from watching composers
Through The Years nobody really went
back even after we had the physical
interpretation and you could say to
someone well you know if you put a
leaning triangle in there you'll be
really simulating a string and they
would try that and they would say Ah
that's kind of thin and boring by
comparison so they went right back to
random numbers
and uh so there's a a richness A
diversity in that that that the real
world can't keep up with this is an
example where the virtual world cut took
out ahead went out ahead of the real
world and and uh and the Gap was never
closed so I I like the virtual world I
think it's a good
place uh you can do things there that
you can't do in the real world you get
your own reality so um now uh David
jaffy was a composer in the music
department uh same time I was a graduate
student inou and he played in a string
quartet with with Alex strong and Alex
said hey you got to hear this algor them
it really sounds good and David listened
to it and said that does sound good you
know because he was at the computer
music center and he heard what we were
getting by with in the way of you know
basically Loop wave TBL uh synthesis for
the most part and uh he said you know
I've got to use this in a piece and he
implemented on all all the synthesizers
we had at the time and I was an engineer
who uh could help him with things like
interpolation and getting it in tune and
adding filters and so this is what we
ended up with um it's got it's basically
an extended carplus strong algorithm
where you basically add uh uh a pick
pick Direction low pass picture filter
that that's to capture the difference in
an up down pick there's a little bit of
a spectral uh difference alternating and
so you just make that filter a little
different going up and down and it
satisfies your ear that you're getting a
reasonable tremolo effect and then
there's a u pick position comb filter
that corresponds to plucking it at
various distances away from the bridge
and um I'll leave it as an exercise to
prove that it comes out in the form of a
comb filter like that and then we have a
string damping filter which is more
General than the twoo average uh then we
also uh added a string stiffness all
pass filter that that gives you stiff
strings for what you need for piano
pianos have uh audibly stiff strings
because what it does is it stretches the
overtones in the U in the sound so it's
not a harmonic vibrating sound it's a
it's a it's a it's somewhere between a
string and a bar so a stiff string is
sort of toward a vibrating bar in terms
of its
overtones okay and then uh these are
those um filters uh that were added uh
the dynamic level low PA pass filter was
to make it brighter when you hit it
harder that's inspired by not only
pianos but even guitars do that it's
it's a a u nonlinear effect in the piano
it comes from the nonlinear compression
of the felt uh there's a power law for
for the uh uh the force that's applied
as a function of compression on the
felt so let's hear it let's hear some of
the uh I don't have the original carong
examples but you can find them on the
web they're eight bits they're U they're
they're not very musical but but David
was a composer and he really uh wanted
to uh harness this thing as musical
instrument and so here are examples from
the syn is toolkit by Perry Cook and
Gary scavone this is the uh software
environment that we use for all of our
physical modeling prototyping well not
all of it but anything hard and advanced
we end up doing it you know in C++ and
the SDK there are some nice uh
programming environments that that work
really well for various CA special cases
but the really General tool is is the
SDK uh so here here's an
example
[Music]
and this just shows a uh a progression
of examples that's a very low
pitch need go up that's a higher pitch
and huh let me rewind
there and then finally I have one
finally have one that goes over the
range this really gives you a sense of
the
[Music]
so that's using the random noise
excitation so this is you can call it
the spuck string it's struck and plucked
everywhere along its length and uh it
doesn't quite sound like a string or a
piano or a clav cord it's it's got its
own sort of space but it's in that
General ballpark another thing about
random numbers is that you know the 48
transform is random numbers so it means
you have a a a completely random initial
spectrum and that's valued uh by
composers because from note to note
there's a liveliness that comes from
that the fact that the spectrum is not
just repeating inexorably every noe's a
little
different but of course you eventually
get to the point where you want to save
your random number seeds you know oh
well and control them and here's here's
an example that we did at next computer
this was used at the introduction of the
next computer in dve Symphony Hall with
the first chair violinist playing the
violin part which is not included this
will just be the orchestra backup for
the bach a minor cherto and it was uh it
was sort of uh unreduced from a piano
reduction uh by the violinist's wife Dan
Kaka and uh David jaffy and uh and
others of us in the music group at next
um worked on the score and the in the
voicing and here's what we came up with
and we got a standing ovation but that's
totally unfair because you know it was
after a fantastic presentation by Steve
Jobs on the new next computer and it was
evation for the whole show but but we
were at the end and it it felt like
[Music]
ours you know that
piece
[Music]
sound system by George coats so the uhu
um that that's just the uh pluck string
uh the uh you basically the extended car
plus strong algorithm running all those
voices running in real time on on a
single Motorola 56,000 DSP chip which
had a clock rate at that time of about
10 MHz so it was a very uh you know uh
it had to be a very efficient algorithm
to run in real time of course that was
you know optimize Assembly Language and
so on uh just the unit generators were
optimized then you could assemble the
unit generators using the high level
music kit so uh you had to write your
inner Loops in Assembly Language to get
the best out of it so all right so that
was um the string early string now we in
the late 80s and so I'm going to uh sort
of pick up the pace a little bit because
it would take too long to really explain
these things but the same basic approach
has been applied to Woodwinds so here's
uh now a delay line used as a woodwind
bore so uh waves going out to the Bell
reflecting off the bell and coming back
down the reflection filter is basically
a low pass filter the high frequencies
go out and that's what you hear the low
frequencies reflect back down the bore
and keep the oscillation going and those
low frequencies that reflect back get
sharpened as they reflect off the read
and so this is the read model uh it's
just one way to formate there a lot of
ways to formulate this so you have mouth
pressure coming in and you have incoming
uh pressure wave ass to be a plane wave
and then and you go through this
nonlinear reflection coefficient that uh
is determined by this table and then
that propagates back down and uh that's
your basic uh clarinet model single
read okay so now here's the s K
clarinet so you can find that by
searching for SDK clarinet we took that
and um and made a uh
flute uh I'm sorry we took the SDK flute
and made a made a flute for the staccato
project at
[Music]
Karma
and here is um here are some examples in
the Yamaha V1 this came out in '94 uh
based on this type of approach and here
is their bamboo
[Music]
flute and then the OBO
bassoon
[Music]
and the tenor saxophone from the V1 I
must have missed oh I have to hit this
sorry
[Music]
for
so that's being played with a with a
mouth pressure sensor a regular keyboard
synthesizer keyboard and a modulation
wheel that is modulation uh of amuser so
you get some of these little dips in the
sound from that so it's really mapping
uh a physical model uh of a saxophone to
a keyboard for keyboard
players who are willing to uh wear a
mouth pressure sensor um I think that
may have been a problem for the product
but uh you know some people could really
play that thing so now B strings can
similarly be um addressed so here we
have two segments of the string because
the bows you know VI um Boe interior and
so here's the same kind of uh model for
the bow string uh friction contact as as
in the uh read you basically just have
this uh uh friction table um formulated
as a nonlinear reflection coefficient uh
that that is now terminating both sides
of the string and so you have the nut on
one side or the finger this maybe should
be a low pass filter for finger damping
there should really even be some
nonlinearity in there for U vibrating
against the fingerboard uh that's always
pretty nonlinear actually and it makes a
difference um and then you have your low
pass reflection F well this is a very
complex filer because the bridge of a
violin sees the uh mod Lo of the
vibration of the instrument so it's a
fairly complex um uh frequency response
to the reflection and then you have your
output violin body and take as many
outputs as you want and map them into
space so that's that's how you can apply
to both strings and here's a an example
by a student on the using the
cello and here's another one by the same
student
[Music]
and I have to say the best example I've
heard to date was by estabon mestra who
was visiting from Barcelona uh while he
was still a PhD student and his research
has to do with performance modeling
modeling the actual you know gestures
and and bringing out the control
functions um and he hooked up his uh
performance measurement data actually in
modeled form and drove the STK uh b. CPP
instrument which is not necessarily a
violin or a viola in other words it
doesn't have a specific body but it um
implements that basic diagram and it
sounded amazing it was the best demo I
had ever heard of the SDK b. CPP uh
class so um it it underscored I mean I
already knew it was true but it really
hit me hard that man we really got to
get the performance uh synthesis right
uh and and the way to do that is you
know measure a lot of performance model
it properly so performance estimation
performance synthesis is is a very
active uh research
area and and good results have been
obtained so now moving on to the
Distortion electric guitar so to make it
distort one thing you can do is put in a
a clipping function and so this is
reminiscent of overdriven tube
amplifiers in guitar amplifiers and so
because we're working in discreete time
we like to minimize aliasing and so it's
nice to work with the least aliasing
nonlinearity and and among non Ian among
odd
functions um which is kind of you know
any all S curves are are odd right then
uh the simplest one the the the most
gentle is the cubic and so the cubic
nonlinearity is is very popular um you
also see more accurate tube simulation
nonlinearities but then you also usually
see an oversampling factor and it's not
uncommon to see a factor of eight over
sampling you know meaning that you know
if you're U if 50 khz is your nominal
sampling rate you know now you're going
have to 400 kiltz for your simulation so
that you don't have this non the because
the nonlinearity generates Overton which
will then uh Alias at half the sampling
rate now in addition to the nonlinearity
you can you can put in amplifier
feedback so this is the amplifier coming
back and driving your strings you know
Pete towns and Ed it a lot a lot of
guitar players you know would get up
against against their uh amplifiers and
make things Howl in a controlled way and
uh Charlie Sullivan at Princeton uh
published this diagram in the computer
music journal and it uh the string model
can be whatever you want but of course
we probably want to use uh you know
something simple like you know order one
computation with delay lines and then
you have your nonlinearity and then uh
amplifier feedback and and typically
these nonlinearities have uh a little
bit of EQ going in and and a and and an
EQ coming out a lot of times you'll roll
off the the high frequencies go through
the nonlinearity and then bring them
back up if you want and you know so
there's a lot of uh work that goes on
there to get the sound that you want
okay let's hear this one this so this is
not that much more expensive than just
the basic string model we're just adding
U cubic Distortion and a feedback path
with a gain for getting some howling and
so let's hear what some of these sound
like
[Music]
you know what it
is so uh RP uh Jimmy
Hendrick this is the amplifier
[Music]
feedback back to square one there this
is being played on a on a midi guitar
controller that is uh going into a midi
interface to a next computer and being
rendered in real time on the Motorola
56000 chip and so here's just another
feedback uh
[Music]
example
see so you can really hear those um
overtones um coming in and the and the
feedback delay of course tells you which
uh which overtones are going to be
favored and tend to to come out like
that all right so then uh the last
synthesis technique I wanted to talk
about was uh commuted synthesis and the
basic idea of commuted synthesis is uh
making use of a the well let's it goes
back to Daniel beri it's the principle
of superposition in linear time
invariance systems um uh you not only
have superposition you also have
commutativity you can run your your
components in any order and so the uh
resonator is really quite um linear in
timing variant in a in a typical
instrument you know it's hard wood and
it's not vibrating very much compared to
its uh shape but the string that's a bit
of a stretch that's an approximation
there's a lot of nonlinear things that
go on in strings and and so that we're
approximating that nonlinearity is not
being there for purposes
of uh making the computation way less
expensive so to the extent that the
string is linear and time in variant um
you can interchange the order of the
resonator and the string and and the
reason this helps is because in this
form the resonator is a gigantic filter
you know there you could say there are
hundreds of thousands of modes resonant
modes in the in the audio band in in
typical stringed instruments you know
the these are Big vibrating bodies with
lots and lots of uh resonances in the uh
in the in the audio band uh particularly
when you get into the cavity resonances
you know because that's a
threedimensional
space and the um uh the density of modes
as a function of frequency uh goes up um
you know in polinomial well what is it
it's um I think it's the or with
frequency squared for U uh strings and
with for for plates and frequency Cub
for for volumes I hope I'm not off by
one there I think that's right so it's
an extreme density of modes and we don't
want to have to implement those with by
quads you know two pole digital filters
so when you interchange the
order the excitation excites this fixed
resonator so really all that ever comes
out of here is the resonator's impulse
response or excitation response so
basically we just need to tabulate this
resonance impulse response maybe
convolve it with some little excitation
filter and then put that out through the
ideal string and we've gotten rid of
this gigantic filter uh you know the
complexity of this model here is you you
know order hundreds of thousands as
opposed to order one for the string and
a simple little uh model for the
excitation I've never seen one more than
order four um you know they're typically
like a little mass and spring thing
maybe with some friction maybe a little
table so excitations are are generally
quite small because they don't store a
lot of energy you you get your
complexity from energy storage and every
resonance is an energy storage degree of
freedom and we get away with Simplicity
for the string because those uh
resonances are Quasi harmonic and so the
delay Line Filter model is extremely
powerful for those um uh phenomena but
not resonances in general although we
can do a lot with um psycho acoustic
simplification of resonator so you don't
really Implement every little Peak uh
you just have to implement it in a
psycho acoustically equivalent way which
we still don't know how to do exactly
but uh that's another research
area all right so that that's the basic
technique and now let's look listen to
some
examples so U
oops uh let's
see well in the SDK you have the
mandolin let's hear
[Music]
that and uh these are some of the
examples from the sius
[Music]
project there's also a whammy bar
simulation and uh there's also a pickup
simulation which just a little simp
simple
[Music]
filter so the main thing that changed
there was the pickup model from single
coil to dual coil all right now here are
some more uh recent examples from
Finland classical
guitar
so we can play you can ask me a question
and uh May me go back to that if you
want so these are now links to the
websites at um Helsinki uh uh University
of Technology and so uh I just say do a
search for acoustic guitars there and
you'll you'll get to their um examples
these are just two links to those but
since I'm low on time I'll U I'll I'll
run along here um now so it can be
applied to the violin and here's some
example play just one example of
commuted synthesis on
[Music]
violin and
uh then finally the idea can be U
applied to piano and the tricky part of
the piano model is that you've got to do
this nonlinear felt compression model
somehow um and so the key observation is
that for a given striking velocity that
Force versus velocity curve is uh force
is a function of striking velocity is a
fixed shape so you can use a linear time
invariant filter to to produce that
shape and that means it will commute
with the piano soundboard and body
enclosure so so in other words
conditioned on striking velocity it's a
linear time invariant model and that
enables the comput commuted synthesis uh
technique and so here's the uh uh sort
of non-c commuted ordering where you
have an Impulse going into tap delay
line putting out low path the reason you
need three here is because sometimes you
get overlapping pulses what happens is
the the hammer drives into the string
and you get several Reflections from the
graph before the hammer finally Falls
away so you need multiple pulses there
that's the purpose for three here it
could be five uh it can also be one and
then you add them up and run to the
string and so now the soundboard
enclosure which is a mammoth huge filter
can now be commuted with everything
given a fixed Collision velocity so you
you've pressed the key the hammer is in
Flight you're not going to change its
velocity it's flying it's got a fixed V
subc we can now build that model on
demand so these filters all assume
they're setting for that Collision
velocity before the hammer gets there
and then boom uh all the soundboard can
come back to the beginning so what we
can do is then hit all this with a
soundboard imp soundboard impulse
response or soundboard and enclosure or
soundboard and enclosure and room you
can put anything you can put all your
linear time and variant shaping filters
in there and they can just be tabulated
and you trigger a playback of that into
the delay line into the low pass folders
into the string and now we're back
to not order one but maybe maybe these
are fourth order um filters so maybe
it's order order four it's really it's
really
cheap
um so well that's still order one excuse
me I'm being recorded I have to correct
myself when I catch something all right
so uh the soundboard enclosure commuted
so let's hear some examples so this is
uh our
piano
and here's our Harps
[Music]
Accord and I'm cutting them off because
uh in Helsinki they have better ones and
I'm going to
play uh they just did a better job you
know they they work with the seus
Institute and the Acoustics group work
together and uh so it's really very
powerful to combine musicians and
Engineers together because the engineers
don't have the ears and uh and they just
need each other and so you put them
together and you get the best results
I've seen it consistently through the
years so that's just what's in the table
that's the the
soundboard uh symbolum here's the U
harbs cord
[Music]
example
I faded them out because I'm out of time
but there there it is you can find on
the website and so I'm out of time and
the last topic is uh Recent research at
Karma so I'll just give you a really
very fast quick overview and then you
can ask me questions about that and we
can get into that in the questions CU we
have um up to a half an hour questions
so uh let me just say very briefly well
maybe up to 27 minutes of questions so
so the uh so the uh quick overview is
basically the students who've been
around Karma recently so this is just a
and those working on you know virtual
musical instrument related research so
I'm not talking anything about the U the
people doing music information retrieval
which is very big these days or you know
all the other topics so Nelson Lee uh
PhD in computer science uh just finished
a thesis on the virtual acoustic guitar
his passion was the gypsy
guitar and so he did a lot of
measurement and uh model building for
that edber doall just graduated and and
he's a a dou PhD was aou PhD student now
he's working at senheiser and um I think
he's doing some collaboration various
labs around the world right now it's
hard to actually keep up with him he's
everywhere doing everything and and one
of his passions is haptic virtual
instruments which is extremely relevant
because when you build a good model you
have to be able to control it somehow
and and so we need good controllers that
allow us to drive these models in a very
natural way that feels right and fully
exercises their dimensions and so um Ed
is working in the hatic uh feedback
control uh domain so that you get
feedback from the controller so it
really feels like the instrument as
opposed to just a one-way connection to
the
instrument Jack P is a PhD in physics
student and he's uh just just got back
from his first conference he went to
dafx and you may have seen it um I was
just going to show one panel from his uh
poster that just gives you the idea of
what he's working on he's basically
working on uh a better mathematical
model of the pleum and the harps of cord
so this is the pleum this yellow ball
here is the string cross-section and so
what happens is when you press a key on
the harpsicord the Jack goes up and
drags the plum past the string and
plucks it and so what Jack has done is
come up with an improved formulation of
this shape so you we know much we have a
much more precise model for how that
pluck occurs and and that's really
valuable because it allows us to U
excite the string uh precisely in all
directions as a result of that
model
so I did not mean to double drag
um so let's get back to the summary I'll
just do the summary and if you ask me a
question I'll go to the expansion slide
on these
so so then then we also have a project
going we call it the shevine project CH
ha v i n um it's uh associated with a
professor of archaeology um Professor
Rick who is uh working in Chile in the
Andes in a in an archaeological site
that's deep underground and it has very
interesting Acoustics and there's
evidence that Acoustics the properties
of the acoustic space are being used in
rituals you know 8,000 years ago so uh
we're involved in in U in acoustic space
modeling associated with that and so
there are a lot of students working in
that
area um and we also just came out with a
special issue if you're in this field
you probably know about this special
issue it's really got a lot of good
papers in it and uh uh vesa valaki um at
Helsinki uh was the the lead editor and
he organized orz a team of us and uh we
got a lot of really good response a lot
of excellent papers so I strongly uh
recommend it's it's the May it's the May
2010 special issue and then um my
personal project activity is in this
area right now basically software tools
high level languages and software tools
for expressing everything we need to
know everything we know how to do in a
few lines of really good highle language
and then being able to compile that into
any kind of plug in in any format for
any platform and so my my current
favorite in that domain sort of the uh
the Pioneer language in my opinion is
the F Language by Yan orari in um gra in
Leon and it's really really nice but it
doesn't do everything so um so I'm
thinking about how can we take this to
The Next Step by by importing some of
these good ideas into the SDK domain in
other words why can't I write a high
level script in some language that we
design that then gets compiled into SDK
code for any platform for any plug-in
format other words we can do the same
kinds we can import these good ideas
from computer science applied to music
and and U and and achieve this Nirvana
of instant Studio on demand uh using any
known technique and you specify in a few
lines and and you're looking at a rack
of virtual gear you know in just a
minute later uh if not less so that
that's the U that's the overview and U I
guess it is time to summarize and
conclude the summary is we U we did a
review kind of a Karma bias slice
through the history of sound synthesis
based on physical modeling starting with
Bern's ingenious insight into
superposition which really launched an
enormous amount and uh you know seeing
modal synthesis in his head uh from
natural vibration and then D Bear's
foundational super position of traveling
waves the first wave equation for
anything really as far as I know unless
you want to call FAL M FAL Ma I don't
know hooks law and I don't know first
string wave equation first partial
differential equation as far as I know
and uh you know before and in boach was
alive uh at the time so U you know it
goes way back uh I have to be very
careful B no that Bach was almost born I
think okay we have to check me on the
dates there
huh wasn't he born in
1750 what he died in 1750 1685 he was
born
okay 1686 maybe um okay so yeah it's
funny you know your memory needs to be
refreshed and I haven't I haven't read a
a you know a biography of Bach recently
and uh yeah 1750 yeah he was definitely
alive but I don't think he was following
the musical AC tics literature at the
time um all right and then and then I
took you through a tour in historical
order of various uh physical model based
syntheses techniques and some sound
examples and uh a very brief uh summary
of of related research going on at Karma
uh you know current and recently
graduated uh graduate students so I'm
only nine minutes over so that's not too
terrible uh and we have time for
questions thank you
thank
you